he recently did a study of future of MIT
education and right at the top what we
have to do is to teach teamwork and
leadership above technical skills and
the neat thing about getting students to
work with visual materials is that
because there's so much information that
you've got to work in teams just having
one perspective is interesting about
having two perspectives it's really
interesting and having multiple
perspectives on the same material is it
is just extraordinary and people debate
and this is something else the idea of
critical thinking you really debate
based on whatever evidence you can find
in the image and historical and cultural
knowledge that you gain from your
readings in the video and so the idea of
teamwork really comes into play and you
can see people playing leadership roles
and people sort of switch leaders
leadership as they go from one image to
the next depending on what they feel
comfortable talking about here's some
things to keep in mind about
incorporating visual materials the first
thing that one should know we know this
already is that young people are exposed
to the visual materials by the tongue on
a daily basis and yet they're never
taught how to interpret them what
happens with visual materials is that
you go in you react emotionally and then
you you come out without carefully
analyzing the content
unlike written material written material
you have to go through word by word and
sort of think about what look what is
this what does this say and so it's
critical that we teach so how to read
visuals that's one point the second
point is that there's a ton of visuals
out there you have to curate them you
can't just throw students
- no this collection of visuals without
some sense of knowing where those
visuals come from if you want students
to publish the visuals and then you have
to think about copyright as students
should be taught about copyright what
things you can and cannot do so these
are all like 21st century skills that
you can teach with visual material